[Música]
o cliente não costuma escolher a
apresentadora negra então na boa eu acho
melhor você nem e no teste o tom da sua
cor de pele não é assim então comercial
nós vamos escolher outra atriz
eu sou uma mulher negra nordestina
brasileira
morei dez anos em são paulo
aqui eu estudei artes cênicas na usp
trabalhei como garçonete para me manter
bem aulas de dança teatro trabalhou em
alguns espetáculos como atriz
e nesse período eu fazia todos os testes
que eu era chamada para fazer um tempo
atrás eu percebi que ao decidir ser
atriz
eu me coloquei na situação de ser muitas
vezes testada e algumas vezes rejeitada
seja porque o cliente não costuma
escolher apresentadora negra em um
produtor de elenco na boa realmente
falou isso sobre mim seja porque eu não
tenho um tipo ideal da maioria das
personagens femininas que o brasil
produz em audiovisual querem ver um
exemplo filmes séries novelas de tv
produzidos no brasil vocês já assistiram
e que era protagonizado por uma atriz
negra melhor quando os cartazes de
filmes
vocês lembram e que tem ali estampado
uma atriz negra de lábios grossos nariz
largo o cabelo crespo 5
bem segundo o ibge
nós negros e pardos somos 54% da
população brasileira segundo uma
pesquisa de um grupo de estudo da
universidade estadual do rio de janeiro
grupo gema mulheres negras e pardas
estão apenas em 4,4 por cento dos filmes
nacionais no elenco principal
nas campanhas publicitárias
estamos protagonizando em 1%
se somos maioria porque não temos
mulheres negras em audiovisual mulheres
negras por acaso não consomem
audiovisual produzido no brasil porque a
gente consome
certamente a gente quer se identificar a
gente quer se ver esses negros só
assistir em produções nas quais se
sintam representados que tenham negros
em papéis não estereotipado os negros
com família melhor se os negros só
consumir 100 produtos nos quais se
sentem representados nas campanhas
publicitárias
o quanto que essas outras produções
produtos e empresas e não perder o que
já não estão perdendo os 50 mais de 50%
da população brasileira tem muita coisa
não
o fato de vermos poucas mulheres negras
no audiovisual brasileiro
simboliza a desvalorização das mulheres
negras no mercado de audiovisual e na
sociedade como um todo bem estou aqui
pontuando a questão do audiovisual
a gente precisa reconhecer que em todos
os setores a nossa sociedade é racista
cadê os negros que ocupam cargos de
poder nas grandes empresas
na equipe de criação da agência
cidade advogados médicos juízes onde
estão
quero fazer outra pergunta quantas
colegas mulheres negras vocês têm os
trabalhos onde você ocupam suas missões
e que tem cargo de poder
isso tudo infelizmente essa
invisibilidade assim como os terreiros
de candomblé que estão sendo invadidos
no brasil né como a gente tem ouvido nos
últimos tempos tudo isso o racismo ea
gente precisa de fato se incomodar com
isso
o racismo é bom pra quem é preciso
fazermos essa reflexão é esse o brasil
que a gente quer que as empresas podem
fazer muito pela eqüidade de gênero e
raça já que está comprovado que a
diversidade é uma vantagem competitiva
colocar negros e mulheres em cargos de
poder políticas de cotas patrocinar
projetos culturais com mulheres negras
com negros
tudo isso não só engrandecem as empresas
mas também a nossa sociedade como um
todo a lidar com essa percepção dessa
invisibilidade muitas vezes nem poder e
me engrandece cada vez mais como uma
típica capricorniano alguém achar que eu
não sou capaz de fazer algo ou não me
dar a devida oportunidade me dar mais
vontade de trabalhar muito até conseguir
lidar com as rejeições me dá mais gana
de querer fazer melhor de querer
protagonizar fazer papéis maiores e de
transformar essa situação em algo
extremamente positivo na minha vida
afinal de contas eu não sou escolher eu
decidir ser atriz e agora também é
produtora executiva e está no topo da
pirâmide social
aliás essa coisa da pirâmide me remete a
uma frase que eu gosto muito e que
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
quando uma mulher negra se movimenta
toda a estrutura da sociedade se
movimenta com ela porque tudo é
desestruturado a partir da base da
pirâmide social onde encontrou seis
mulheres negras
isso porque muda se a base do
capitalismo
ao começar me mover na base dessa
pirâmide
eu comecei a perceber que os maiores
atores norte-americanos negros mulheres
produzem são produtores executivos de
seus filmes feres protagonismo e até
criam as suas próprias histórias
foi quando me dei conta também que o
audiovisual brasileiro como mercado
majoritariamente branco e masculino nas
posições de maior poder necessita de mim
não sou uma atriz mas também do meu
ponto de vista o ponto de vista de
mulheres negras como eu pra novas
histórias novos protagonismos e novas
produções e embalada por um senso de
propósito
hoje além de atuar com muito respeito
nas produções de outros realizadores
eu tenho a minha produtora para criar
novas histórias minhas fontes de
inspiração não essas imagens imagens de
filmes séries de tv produzido nos
estados unidos com empoderamento
protagonismo negro e feminino e que são
amplamente comerciais porque tudo só
depende do ponto de vista
eu quero criar histórias com mulheres
negras como eu de nariz lar com o cabelo
crespo lábios grossos que entretém e que
emocione e que seja amplamente
comerciais já que tudo só depende de
ponto de vista
a sociedade está começando a perceber
que a gente está migrando da era da
idealização mulheres muito difundida
através da publicidade no qual explora
um padrão de beleza estética
pré-definido
estamos indo pra era da identificação
eu não me vejo no consumo conceito aliás
muito em voga nos estados unidos há
muito tempo eu tenho outra frase que eu
gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
essa frase é de shonda rhimes para quem
não a conhece
ela é uma das maiores criadoras de
audiovisual dos estados unidos
é mais ou menos assim eu odeio demais a
palavra diversidade sugere algo especial
diverso como se fosse em comum criar
histórias com mulheres e pessoas de cor
de uma palavra diferente normalizar
eu estou normalizando a tv porque estou
fazendo a tv se parecer mais com o mundo
real somam mais de 50%
isso significa que eles não são qualquer
coisa eu tenho um sonho sonho com brasil
que rompa velhas estruturas de
privilégios velhos paradigmas
estereótipos e mitos como da democracia
racial e vocês vamos sonhar e realizar
juntos
obrigada
[Aplausos]